Hello BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts on FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for our 162nd episode!
I knew it would happen.
I knew something would get mistaken today.
I was just thinking about how happy I was to be able to spend the morning together with the Ruffians.
And then you go ahead of yourself.
FUWAMOCO!
Put it here Ruffians!
I'm not waiting a new week and a new month because it's not June 2nd.
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you Ruffians for being here together with us for the start of a new month and new FUWAMOCO Morning.
But for Ruffians that are joining us maybe for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show
Every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
So FUWAMOCO can try to balance their lives, yes!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You know, it's a new month.
Things are maybe a little bit different for FUWAMOCO Morning.
But not.
June.
Because it's June.
It's officially summer now.
It's starting to get hot.
Does that mean it's officially summer?
I think so, Moco-chan.
May need to get a cold in spring.
No more sweaters.
Yeah.
No more hiding those arms, Moco-chan.
But Ruffians, we also gotta make sure sunscreen, okay?
Yes!
Sunscreen!
And remember to hydrate, too.
It's the morning, which means you definitely, definitely need to get some water.
Yes!
Not just coffee, okay?
Water!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't wanna share.
Huh?
Don't wanna share.
Got this.
Pero, Pero, Pero Sighting.
Ruffians think it's Pero.
There's been another Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
You wanna see where he is?
Let's see where Pero was Sighted this time.
Okie!
Okie.
Dad!
Pero got an oshi?
Is that oshi us?
Was he cheering for us?
Well, you know what?
He's nasty!
And, uh, he does say a lot of things about Pero.
You know, we do know him a lot better than you, Ruffian.
I'm curious.
But, if he's going to cheer for us like this, together with the Ruffians, maybe that's pretty nice of him.
Right.
Maybe we should treat him a little bit more kindly?
That's nice of him.
Yeah, you know, if that's how he feels towards us, then... I guess.
That's pretty nice.
Yeah.
I mean, it'd be nice if he was cheering on any World Members too, but... But!
I think... Pero, you know, he needs to get his own happy life.
He can't just steal yours, you know!
But yeah... But... You know, everyone cheering for us is precious, so... Maybe...
Now let's call Nasty.
BAU BAU!
Are we happy about this?
Mixed.
BAU BAU!
Please be careful, Ruffians.
You want to make sure you keep a good eye on all your happy, your merch and everything.
Good bye Metal Gear Solid!
FUWAMOCO!
But we finally reached the end of Metal Gear Solid 3!
And what a thrill it was!
What a thrill, what an epic!
You know, every game was so different!
Very thrilling.
And I definitely mastered Stealth and QCQ.
It was a very FUWAMOCO, fluffy and fuzzy playthrough of all the games.
So Ruffians, you know, maybe you haven't seen our playthrough of Metal Gear Solid.
Metal Gear Solid 2.
Please take a look at Metal Gear Solid 3 too!
Extra silly moments about the right.
Moco-chan, the boss battle there, without any spoilers, was very interesting, right?
Got pretty angry at points.
So angry you became a horse?
And we had you know, during the Metal Gear Solid series, we had some good things, you know, with our dance parties.
Dance.
Vampire.
You know conclusion of that.
But we really really enjoyed it.
We enjoyed being able to show a game that's really special to you Ruffians and also maybe a first time for some Ruffians too.
But we know there's more Metal Gear Solid games but this is the end of the road for us for now.
Thank you Ruffians!
We had fun!
It was fun!
BAU BAU!
Good memories remain.
It was your first time!
BAU BAU!
Both the first time though.
But you know, speaking first time, that's true!
A birthday coming up.
It's gonna be Hajime's very first 3D birthday live!
Congratulations Hajime!
On the 7th at 8pm JST or 4am PT.
It's going to be Hajime's birthday!
And the title of the concert is First Starring Role.
I thought it was sort of funny.
It's so cool.
It's so cool!
Why is the pony Moco-chan?
I thought...
Wow, FUWAMOCO.
I never think of such a cool title.
That is true.
Right!
And I actually think that there might be lots of dancing.
Wow, very cool.
Right, you know, and this illustration too, Hajime.
Hajime's, I think, done some stretching.
Yes!
It's ready to- I would hope!
To show the results of those stretches.
You know, and it looks like there's also gonna be a big announcement too.
Oh, big announcement.
Very cool.
I wonder if they'll be guests too!
We'll have to see!
I'm looking forward to it though!
What kind of performances Hajime gonna show us?
And you know!
Birthday girl!
We gotta wish that birthday girl a big happy birthday too!
Look at the time.
I guess you could, you know.
Or you could admire the deep stretching, you know.
Or you could look at the face like a normal person.
BAU BAU.
I get lost in Hajime's eyes.
But happy early birthday Hajime!
BAU BAU!
There's a lot of exciting things going on, you know.
First day after 7th anniversary!
That's crazy!
Oh my gosh, hololive just keeps on, you know, growing!
Not being miles, though.
7 years?
7 is a lot!
I'm going on to a 3rd year hololive!
BAU BAU!
Actually, there was an interesting observation that a Ruffian came across this, shared it with us.
But, let's take a look at this.
This is spotted at, I kinda guess a mall overseas.
Looks kind of familiar.
Hmm.
Kinda interesting.
Is this a coincidence, maybe?
Hmm.
Whoa.
That's really, really similar, yeah.
Similar.
Why?
Maybe they got inspiration.
Maybe you know where the trendsetters and fashion!
Trendsetters!
FUWAMOCO trendsetters!
Fashion trendsetters!
You know, sometimes I see
FUWAMOCO Nails!
They're so cute!
Very cute, but you know, by setting the trends for what's in style, you know, the summer look is looking extra fluffy and fuzzy this year.
Yeah, definitely summer.
I definitely want to be very fluffy in summer, huh?
Hi!
Yeah, we're the trendsetters.
I'm so happy!
Yeah!
I think it's a good choice and fashion.
Yeah, if it's just a coincidence.
I'm happy that you know you look at the word.
That's FUWAMOCO!
We're there!
We're there near the bar!
Maybe you know, maybe you're like, oh, this store is near where I am.
You can go get your own inspired FUWAMOCO code there too!
Lots of ideas!
Perfect for this season!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
So cool, so sweet.
Well, next, you know, we've been talking about all the exciting things going on at hololive.
There was another exciting idea project just announced!
And it was announced by Botan-senpai!
Because there's a new big big hololive
Minecraft server about to happen!
The hololive Minecraft Gold Rush Survival!
So we will explain what is happening.
So it's gonna be happening in Minecraft!
All together with hololive ID, IAN and JP!
And the voice as well!
I see Botan-senpai.
She brought money to the world of Minecraft.
And we're all gonna do within 5 days.
We're going to try and make as much money as possible.
Yes, that is the goal.
That is the goal.
It's gonna be starting June 9th from 7pm to midnight JST.
Which is 3am.
P.T.
on the 9th and it's gonna end on the 13th!
So, we have about five days to be able to get as much money as possible.
But, how do we make money?
Right, well there's lots of different ways we can make money.
Let's take a look.
On the first day, we have a bunch of different jobs that we can choose.
On the first day, we're gonna be jobless, I think.
You know, so that we can kind of figure out what suits us best.
But from the second day, we'll be choosing classes.
First, we have the Adventurer.
You know where you can make money by defeating monsters by fishing.
You know Minecraft things.
We like to fight monsters.
Definitely FUWAMO likes it, the witches.
I need to kill a witch!
I also have a money man in the class.
You can defeat the blocks, break the blocks, and get money that way.
Apparently there's an attitude system too so that you can't just break a block, place a block, break a block, place a block.
Oh, but I feel like that's fair, no?
Really?
Why not?
You're doing the work.
Go around and break the blocks.
Not break place, break place.
You know?
Yeah.
Not fair!
I guess if you say so, Ruffians.
And next we have the farm way.
The farm way, you know.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I don't know chickens apply for this.
I guess I did not, that's a farm.
You need chickens on a farm.
Are you just gonna have cows and pigs?
And sheep.
And chicken.
This is a job for everyone!
Yes!
And next we have the... Researcher!
Researcher!
You know you can make potions, do enchantments, repairs... I don't know if this is the FUWAMOCO type job class.
I do not know how to make items well.
I don't know what's a potion.
I've never enchanted something and...
I didn't know you could repair.
But you can make money this way.
I think this is not ours.
And Botan-senpai is saying it comes really in handy near the end too.
Makes you think.
Yeah.
But you know, it is a five day event.
And maybe not all members can play every single day.
So there's some other things that kind of maybe level things out, even things out.
Yeah.
But there's the arena!
So you can get all together and make a party!
And then take down some very strong monsters!
Apparently you cannot do it really on your own.
No.
They're very strong.
Sally Botan-senpai said something about original monsters.
We'll have to see!
There's also LAMVIGUS!
It's here!
The whole Minecraft!
There's Rush Survival Server.
There's a roulette and also the slots.
And so you can play them, you can get your tokens and then you can exchange them for money.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
That's one way to make some extra money.
Do you have anything else?
We have the stock market!
There'll be three different types of stocks that you can purchase.
Butan-senpai is gonna be the game master, so every hour she's gonna spin a wheel.
And I guess that determines if the stocks go up or if they go down.
But she says generally, as long as you make sure to sell when they're high and buy when they're low, then it should go well for you.
As long as you remember that.
Let's start.
Sell high, buy low.
Not buy high, sell low.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
But I think that sounds fun, you know?
Going on an adventure all together with everybody.
Just to make sure you're first, maybe.
Can you split it?
Oh, good question.
I don't know.
There's also other events that will be happening on the different days.
I don't think there's going to be an event happening on the first day, but throughout the event, there'll be different things we can do.
An athletic test.
Fishing eternally!
Some mini-games!
And also snakes and lalas!
This way we can also make some money, especially for other hololive members that might not be able to play everyday.
This is a good way to kinda get a leg up, get some more money in your pocket, and get close to winning.
Mini-games, mini-games!
Right!
So many things to do!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be playing too!
Yes!
We're not very... We're still beginners at Minecraft, but we're really looking forward to doing our best trying to earn as much money as possible and playing together with our senpai too.
How many days do you think you'll be participating for?
That's a good question.
I think most of them.
We'd like to do most of them, but it's also kind of up in the air a little bit.
The schedule, I don't know.
What's going on tomorrow?
I don't know.
But it'll be lots of fun!
Thank you so much Kabuta-senpai for organizing this, arranging this, and everything!
I'm really excited!
So let's cheer on the event and enjoy it all together!
BAU BAU!
You know, it's been a while since the last big group event, right?
At Minecraft!
Exciting, you know, with the new server and everything.
FUWAMOCO is super excited.
We played the first day and then we got really busy and weren't able to play much more.
So, we're excited to be able to have a very good opportunity to play together with everybody, so... BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Monday!
New week, a new month.
You know what Monday means?
Excitement.
It's Monday!
Not blues, right?
They say Monday blues.
Which one is it for you, Ruffians?
A new challenge.
Nattou.
Okay, Moco- No!
You know, I was thinking that, especially with it being a new month and it may be getting a little bit hotter now, maybe Ruffians need a little bit more...pop in your day.
Even though it's a Wednesday!
Moco-chan, maybe have something to share with the Ruffians.
Ruffians!
It's a different day of the week so maybe it's a bit surprising but it's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
I know it's probably been a bit rough recently but
I know you keep on doing your best, even when you're tired and you feel like you're too exhausted to carry on.
But you know what?
You're doing it!
You're doing so well!
I know you're super strong, so why can't you see that yourself, silly?
Even if you don't believe in yourself all the time.
We do!
FUWAMOCO believes in you!
We're always cheering you on, so keep at it even when you stumble.
Okay?
We're so proud!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Keep on at it, okay?
I love you!
You got it!
It'll be an amazing month, okay?
Let's make it so.
BAU BAU!
It's that time again!
It's the time for a Doggie of the Day!
Let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day today.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Mochi!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, doggy, for today.
It is Mochi's birthday on the 21st!
Happy birthday, Mochi!
This doggy still loves cuddling and sunbathing, too.
Very cute.
I don't know, I don't really... Some things are not quite my thing, but... Oh, look at her here!
Do you see her?
Every doggy's different.
She's camouflaged into the sofa!
That's true.
Yeah!
What do you think?
Snake, let me prowl at it!
I think so, yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, what is this camouflage?
That's snake action?
No!
This is Mochi!
What is this camo for?
It's not chocochip, but... Mochi Mochi.
Mochi Mochi.
There you go!
Yes!
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Mochi BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
Very cute.
Like that.
Like that?
Yes!
Wow!
Mochi is the best doggy!
You put her in front of me.
Mochi!
Then we just eat her all up!
She's so cute!
That's Mochi.
BAU BAU!
Looks delicious.
That's the Doggie of the Day!
And!
Next we have what "Today I Went on a Walk" corner!
Ruffians, it's about the summer time!
You're gonna get outside!
Now is the time!
So let's take a look what this Ruffian wears!
We have... De-den!
What is that?
Salt ponds!
Oh my gosh.
They look pink.
Right!
Red?
Red.
Kinda reminds me a little bit of Evangelion.
I wanna see that Moco-chan.
I would though.
I would try though.
Is it not allowed?
It's really bad for you.
Okay!
Maybe you just have to bring some salt in your pocket, and you can just lick that, and then you're like, enjoy the experience.
Like a cafe where you bring your own coffee.
Yeah, like that kind of, yeah, just like that.
But, you know the beach kind of smells kind of salty and silly and funny, and FUWAMOCO don't feel sick at the beach because it smells.
But did it smell like that, but at times... Did you have fun?
I wonder what you do with the salt, the salt ponds.
You know, I was never giving it a bit overwhelmed by the beach.
Yeah.
What does the city smell like?
The beach.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO don't do well at the beach.
Not really.
I hope we didn't throw up.
This is the sun.
I don't know.
I think this is really cool.
I wanna go too.
As long as I don't throw up.
BAU BAU!
We hope you have fun.
Overwhelming beats.
BAU BAU!
Well, next we have our Question of the Day.
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
-Hi FUWAMOCO!
-Hello!
After returning from Japan, I'm feeling motivated to further improve my Japanese to prepare for next time.
Another Japan trip.
My gosh.
Do you have any tips for Ruffians who want to start learning or want to get more fluent?
BAU BAU!
Very good question!
I think this is on the minds of lots of Ruffians.
For FUWAMOCO, first, have fun.
Have fun.
You know, and kind of language learning can't always be fun at times, so you know, things like watching anime and just being like, oh, maybe you recognize this.
You're like, oh, this kind of sounds like this, and kind of repeat the sound.
Maybe you can look into it more, you know.
Sometimes there's games that have both English and Japanese at the same time in some official novels.
Maybe you could kind of check those out too.
But you know, immersing yourself really good, you know?
Maybe one idea.
Immersing yourself but then also switching it back to English and you'll be like, ah!
I recognize this!
Oh yeah.
But you know, maybe like making a Twitter account and talking with some JP Ruffians.
You kind of start using some JP, Japanese and little bits here and there, you know?
Could be a good practice.
That mindset is more than half the battle, okay?
I think so.
Don't let that get to you, okay?
No.
It's just a big puzzle.
Yeah.
And it's important to make mistakes.
Yes.
You learn from your mistakes.
So you want to make the mistakes.
You want to be extra silly.
And then think, oh... Yeah.
Call the tsuma, the wife, the uma, the horse.
Yes.
You know, make all of those mistakes.
Or ask for ohashi-yuzera, ohiya.
Yeah, you know, ask for the chopsticks instead of the glass of water.
It's definitely a place with
We don't use chopsticks.
It's definitely a math, but not a space.
I think, you know, that especially being like, okay, I have to learn this much a day, maybe that might be a bit rough on you.
Maybe you'll start to feel a bit like a chore.
Just go at your own pace.
Have fun.
I think having, you know, maybe talking to some Ruffians, you know, maybe there's other Ruffians learning Japanese too.
We can all talk together.
You know, make mistakes together.
And also have fun.
Most important thing is having fun.
Have fun.
Make mistakes.
BAU BAU!
Thank you! Good luck!
We hope your next trip is even more fun than your first trip.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make
Together Ruffians!
And now, temporarily, it's once a week.
So, please remember, you know, throughout your week, maybe you see Pero.
Maybe you have a very cute Doggie of the Day, or a question pops into your mind.
Or where you go for a nice walk.
Please share it with us with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Yes, don't be greedy, Shiori.
Okay, Ruffians!
Please share your life with us!
And maybe it'll be on the next FUWAMOCO Morning!
I said don't be greedy, but then you said share your life with us.
That's pretty greedy.
I'm greedy.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Oh, we have another stream coming up!
Yes!
Let's take a look!
Our next stream is... De-den!
Super chat reading!
Finally, Ruffians!
We're gonna be doing some chatting all together.
It gets super duper cozy!
And we'll be reading some of your super chats!
Yes! Thank you so much for waiting!
Thank you, Ruffians!
All your patience with us.
I know.
I think you know, but things have been extra silly for us.
It's been an interesting spring.
But thank you Ruffians for being so patient.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
We have a new schedule for a new week and a new month!
And this week, we're gonna be continuing to play some more Old Market Simulator all together with Advent on Wednesday.
Right?
You know we're getting pretty far, we can make potions?
Love potions?
I don't know, love potions?
Does everyone want to buy love potions?
Right, well there's going to be Valentine's Day coming up soon, so we want to get all prepared for that in the game.
And hopefully we can make more money!
Make it even more, better, old market!
An almost new market!
Oh!
Yeah, all together with Advent!
And after that!
Well, we have a home market.
We'll be doing homework.
But on Friday, the PS2 is going back on because we're continuing Fatal Frame.
It's a classic horror game and it started on the PS2 so we're starting from the very beginning.
We've been exploring Himuro Mountain, looking for our brother.
And hopefully this week we can complete it!
That's the goal.
So we'll be playing it on Friday and Saturday!
Back with Fatal Frame, yeah!
I bet it's been a lot of fun.
We'll continue using our camera.
Hopefully we can get some even better photos.
We took some nice photos in Metal Gear Solid 3.
Maybe we can take even more nice photos.
More ghosts.
Less frogs.
And better frame.
Guess Eva will show up though, huh?
Who wanted a photo of Eva?
Too bad.
Maybe we can get a photo with her brother, though.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
And on Sunday we have another recording day.
But!
A lot of fun things going on.
Thank you Ruffians!
And!
For the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCODEWORD is... BAU BAU JUNE STYLE!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians...
Temporarily on my knees.
So if you're wondering where the FUWAMOCO Morning went, that's where it is.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Just in case there are some Ruffians who are extra sleepy and maybe missed a little bit of the beginning.
But thank you so much for joining us today, FUWAMOCO Morning Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Leon!
BAU BAU!
Joker!
hololive.
BAU BAU!
Dummy.
Hana.
BAU BAU!
Uno.
Rhyborg.
BAU BAU!
Babytastic.
Berserk Bark.
BAU BAU!
Hibiki.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!